il est dans la famille des mortemart
depuis 200 ans mais c'est un château qui
a vu sa première construction il ya à
peu près mille ans et qui a toujours été
transmises de génération en génération
[Musique]
charles de chaumont d'amboise était
gouverneur du milanais pour louis xii il
allait régulièrement en italie il ya
rencontré des artistes des peintres des
sculpteurs
il s'est dit je vais les ramener avec
moi au château de meillant pour
contribuer à l'embellissement du château
avec donc de l'inspiration italienne
puisque ces artistes étaient les élèves
de léonard de vinci
cette cheminée déjà est unique en france
parce qu'elle est très très grande
vous avez une cheminée en bas qui est
surplombée d'une galerie avec un
escalier dérobé juste derrière les
boiseries et des musiciens pouvaient
monter jouer je vous laisse imaginer la
fournaise que ça devait être puisqu'il
se trouvait juste au dessus du feu ce
sont les fameux artistes élèves de
léonard de vinci qui ont inspiré la
construction et l'embellissement de
cette tour est sûre cette tour on peut
voir justement les armes parlant de
charles de chaumont qui se trouvent être
les deux c entrelacés avec les monts
enflammé qui sont donc des mon show est
à l'envers ça fait chaumont comme
charles de chaumont ça faisait donc
office de sculptures et c'était donc un
rébus et les armes parlante de charles
de chaumont
on a en effet louis xii qui est venu une
fois à meilhan et lorsqu'il est arrivé
il était furieux parce que déjà il
s'était embourbé mais surtout personne
n'était là pour l'accueillir
la famille était en italie donc
l'histoire raconte qu'il aurait laissé
un charmant petit billet 10 ans ou cher
cousin je suis venu à me liant vous n'y
étiez pas je me trouvais que votre
mais que le diable remporté si je
reviens jamais et il n'est jamais revenu
[Musique]